последнее время очень много развелось
такого карта желания мне не нужен
тайм-менеджмент мне не нужен кайдзен и
нужно выгрызать свое место под солнцем
конкуренция бешено работать
без 100 раз не ставить задачи за друга
то забирают ну combined ну окей ну
пандемию
новые планы
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
добрый вечер друзья приветствуем вас на
очередном нашем выпуске нашего подкаста
гемба подкаст это сегодня у нас второй
выпуск 1 выпуск напомню был посвящен в
это вселенной на котором
присутствовали были гостями различные
представители различных айти компаний и
и люди которые не имеют никакого
отношения к ти бизнесу и вообще какие
вселенной но сегодняшняя тема нашего
герба подкаста это планирование и жизнь
и кстати напомню для тех кто первый раз
присоединиться к нашему подкасту что
значит гемба подкаст в японской
технологии кайзен кайзен технологий для
тех кто не знает эта технология на
основе которой поднялась компания тойота
gameboy называет место где возникает
проблема и куда начальство поднимай свою
задницу
спускаются и принимает решение это .
принятии решений так и здесь наш
сегодняшний черный стол олицетворяет то
место куда мы выкладываем проблемы
которые беспокоит нашего общества наших
подписчиков и мы начинаем разбирать эти
проблемы и высказывать свои точки зрения
спорить и ругаться шутить веселиться
надеюсь итак друзья как вы видите
сегодня мы за столом собрались
специально такую разномастные
разношерстную команду
сегодня с нами сидят и представители
творческих профессий и представители
жесткого как многие думают такого
прагматичного планового бизнеса мы
сегодня попытаемся поговорить как мы
вообще относится к планированию как мы
сами выстраиваем выстраиваем свою жизнь
и вообще поговорим о хайпе о новых
веяниях тенденциях которые существуют на
рынке мимо бизнеса и так далее так далее
итак давайте друзья приступим к первой
части нашего подкаста я хотел бы поднять
вопрос я сулит такие моменты вот сейчас
очень много коучей
которые учат людей жить я не буду никого
осуждать это не моих правилах но вы есть
учетка и кто-то покупать начнет кому-то
нужно и я вообще считаю что если кто-то
кого-то обучает и кто-то там покупает и
не довольны этим ну есть же что такой
способ но обучать люди должны обжигаться
сталкиваясь с некачественным продуктом и
в этом плане люди продающие не
качественные знания и некачественный
информации они тоже выполняют
определенную санитарную социальную роль
в последнее время очень много развелось
так а вот карта желания
визуализация там составление списков
даже есть какой-то там составляя список
потом поджигают
елки
[смех]
начни строго у нас на шри-ланке это
делается вот так
я на самом деле я забываю все желание
которые за году ниша по смене раздел но
работает смысл кабуле работает
я думаю я думаю что
я согласен коуч и сейчас их развелось и
да пусть будут вас нет кто то покупает
ради бога проблема я
как и многие люди 15 лет назад посмотрел
фильм секрет которую всем был нам открыт
и ну да ты практикуешь что то что то
получается что то нет но большое
открытие было для меня два года назад
когда я открыла для себя джо dispenser
читали наверное ничего
я по образованию инженер и для меня этот
человек его трактовка вот этой все карты
желаний визуализации намного ближе
потому что он объяснил все как это
работает через квантовую физику через
известно опыт наблюдателя
[музыка]
занимала право мне знать и вот он очень
четко объяснил как работает наша сила
мысли через квантовую физику и
вот те кто скептически к этому относятся
ко всему
попробуйте почитать или хотя бы
аудиокнигу послушать и это работает вот
реально я уход просто расскажу кейс
мы ездили в этом можно секундочку в
топку закинул вадим делом даже зеланда
оттуда но сделать не объясняет через
понятные какие-то формы он говорит вот
так делайте и будет все реже возникает
вопрос а как этой работе друг друга
дополняется когда я жил в топку мама
сито говорил о том же сам
[музыка]
вот расскажу просто последний самый
свежий случай
мы поехали до съемки на третий курс кого
озеро это мы проходили через село
который мне знать не знал ни когда вы
знаете о силе фармит очень красивая мире
милая деревне но все туристы которые еду
на курсе сквозь иране проезжать мимо
него потому что нет вывески его не видно
в другому щели и вот мы прошли через эту
силу и так вау какое крутое место вот бы
здесь что-нибудь построить какой
гостевой дом то что перспектива огромное
нужно он ближе колеса юта мне не
звёздные тропы ущелья красивы я проезжаю
мимо одного места вот это прям вообще
пятак классный и умер это мнение не
реально здесь купить землю все все уже
купили ждут бума и тут я приезжаю в
город
сажусь буквально день прошел на связи
через день я сажусь в кофейне пишет
сценарий и ко мне подходит человек сзади
меня хлопает по плечу ануар можно
сампери грудь и блюдо что-то я живу ну у
нас есть земля поселке кроме то и
мы ищем инвестора партнера кто мог бы
что не построить вам было бы интересно и
внука покажу эту землю и он показывает
ту землю которая проходит два дня назад
в селе о котором я знать не знал до
этого у меня есть эта логическая
объясни-ка это как раз таки к стати на
тему предыдущего выпуска планета
вселенной я думаю что фейсбук
audi
audi отчитывает потом на кону заказал об
этом и вам фэйсбуке работает
назад я ушел уже дано виду чем в 3d
вчера кстати посмотрите вчера я почитал
прочитал пост олега верховского
основаниям она банк и он говорит вы не
поверите я со своим другом по телефону
что-то там говорил насчет того что я
лечу мальдивы нам одним из семей и в
такой-то отель по телефону друга того
классно не тоже классно ты хороший отель
и друга сегодня у меня цела дым в
рекламе инстаграма этот отель не
проблема в том что он даже поговорил то
есть это же как-то объясняется а есть
когда телефон просто лежит и никому не
звонишь ты там про просто разговаривали
на такой чудо и потом тебе предлагается
это самая чонко разговаривали уже не раз
глазами ожидает
это это не про визуализацию друзья
то что как работает просто механизм то
есть то есть
ловили корейские компании которые
следили за происходящим дома при помощи
телевизоров да то есть и давали потом
какие-то рекламные предложения в
зависимости от того что у человека дома
находилась телефон воцап ловили на этом
когда переписки пишешь там ой классно бы
приобрести там куртку canada goose потом
заходишь на facebook а тебе все время
это куртка попадает сам ленте но то есть
это в принципе уже доказанный факт мы то
говорим о чем-то метафизическом вот о
чем говоришь фейсбук еще не знают о
существовании поселка кроме того такого
тега тоже может быть даже нет даже в
google и неправильно человек подошел
человек подошел и так как это объяснить
сложно объяснить вот вы рассказывали мой
гонка дочь врача напомнить между я тоже
хотела что же из этого
анимации на фейсбук а не было тогда 90-е
года выйдем расскажите как здесь вопрос
такое что я я абсолютно в это виду и в
моей жизни происходило очень много чудес
поэтому я абсолютно не противник того
что там такого не бывает более того со
мной было так мы могут чудес что никакая
теория вероятности это объяснить не
может потому что я сама увлекаюсь его у
теории вероятности там теории игр
статистикой а это увлекаюсь это сфера их
интересов но вот просто никакая теория
вероятность не работают во всех этих
вещах я вам расскажу один случай про
чаны и многие знают а вот я вам такое
скажу
2015 год
2015 год я еще одна нахожусь повышу в
судах денег нет и
я своей супруге говорил в свое время
когда когда-то и когда я провел
appealing банка то все я решил подругой
супруги сделать подарок и купил
сережки за миллион долларов
за миллион долларов купил сережки и но
думу крутые сережки вот такими
бриллиантами камнями все
нормально 15 год денег нет у меня всего
5 я супруг город мне нужно для старта
что boost бизнесу дать мне нужны деньги
давай продадим сережки а на 5 ну хорошо
мы начинаем рыть документы в результате
вот этих постоянных обысков перевозок
документов и так далее документов нет
пропали документ сережки есть сережки я
гуру блин это что получается мы остались
на руках с двумя стекляшками нож кому я
докажу это это к экспертизу где это
нанимает это просто стекляшки и я такой
да ну нафиг книгу как ты этот надо
куда-то спрятать . ну вот ну я откуда
знал эти же в области всегда внезапной
то есть ну ладно это было я хорошо помню
это было 11 марта
13 награждение
не
перетянули жестко а детства марта 2000
15 года а сережки я купил в июле 2000
года это получается прошло 8 лет восемь
лет за восемь лет как я купил никаких
вестей от производителя ничего не было а
сережки по моему
chopard и
это было 11 марта проходит неделя 17
март даже неполная недели приходит
письмо мне
от шеппарда
открываю письмо и там говорится вы в
2000 седьмом году купили бриллиантовые
сережки и под номером таким-то таким-то
лимитированной версией с чистотой
такой-то такой-то магазине таком-то
таком-то по кредитной карточке такой-то
такой-то
настоящим письмом
подтверждаем право собственности и то
что вашей сережки зарегистрированных за
вашим номером таким-то таким-то
регистрационный номер такой-то и
сообщаем что рыночная цена этих сережек
составляет миллион семьсот шестьдесят
тысяч долларов на сегодняшний день
подорожают что-то очень богатому зимы не
и и об и представляете [__] недель и
это было единственное письмо с 2000
седьмого года до 22 года защита за 15
лет я получил всего единственное письмо
от chopard единственное что он очень
злой третий раз вы признать chopard 17
марта
рождением
[смех]
ну то есть мы выжили в это время вместе
но так вот смотри за 15 лет получается
shope ни разу мне не писал даже здрасте
ни разу не даже в коменте никогда не
писал так вот присылает письмо и ровно
на седьмой день после того как мы об
этом говорили и за 15 лет всего один раз
мы заговорили о том чтобы продать ярушке
и именно в это время нет теперь самое
главное вы продали сережки нет
потому что в какой-то момент я понял что
стиль ушки являются эмиссионным
инструментом они растут цены очень даже
за восемь лет
семьдесят пять процентов а
ведь женщины об этом часто говорят мы
думаем что это ерунда к цене на самом
деле и весом и ценность имеют если
бриллианты уникальные если уникальные
номерные вот там как раз такая экономика
я называю блокбастеров что в цене растут
самый уникальный один процент
бриллиантов очень сильно растут все
страсти
к лицу но что эти считаются
коллекционными а все остальное это
просто на самом деле стекляшки лучшие
друзья женщин
утраченный деньги
если
допустить да нет но я к тому что
до по факту есть такие законы это
работает я много раз жизни убеждался
действительно изумительно необъяснимо но
мы сейчас говорим не о том что
работает ли метафизики мир мы я думаю
все согласятся что работает мало кто
может отрицать что существует такое
понятие как сглаз как везение
визуального
визуализация и так далее но все таки
если мы
говорим вот одна одно направление вот
эта карта желаний когда пишешь насколько
насколько это работа искусственно и
вопрос мазаник нужно этим у проблем
можно ли научить визуализации то есть
вот то что вы умеете делать вы можете
меня научить
вот так вот предвидеть что со мною через
неделю свяжутся там нужно
четыре недели просто ты меняешься
полностью свое мышление но через
медитации есть не просто нужно увидеть
он очень простое просто объяснять не
просто нужно увидеть картинку нужно ее
представить почувствовать на себе вот
хочешь бюджет правит ты должен внутри
уже быть готовым то есть позволить уже
давно готов
что нужно во-первых представить картинку
подать сигнал картинки и эмоциональный
сигнал я готов есть такая теория
нас этому учили классический подход
нужно выгрызать свое место под солнцем
конкуренция можно работать по хивы есть
вторая концепция вселенная просто в
обилии вселенной она безгранична и она у
нас на самом деле да ведь постоянно но
наши комплексы наши страхи наоборот
закрывает eda.ru а я не готов есть очень
много людей которые боятся больших денег
они вроде бы хотят хотят быть богатыми
но у них есть подсознанию большие деньги
большие проблемы деньги меняют людей
точнее портя да и вот этих установок
нужно конечно избегать пение фобия
называется так психологии пения фобия
назвать 7up тебе ну то есть условно
говоря нуард какое количество людей
прочитала
или там прослужила его где они не знают
вопрос такой что и сколько из них не на
джесс направляешь про виджет и тот же
вопрос это будет я лично про правила и
джед еще не мечтал потому что ну пока я
не вижу один здесь
я
[музыка]
правый прикинь будут несколько часов и
ты уже шри-ланки ну классно же
она нам прямые рейсы из он тоже ну там
не очень удобно смотрел интервью одного
человека который сказал что нафиг этой
авто вы бы столько проблем продал и все
и джед но и при этом сказал надо их
арендовать
месяц моей собственности а давайте ребят
все таки хорошо с этим визуализации мы я
думал хорошо мы видели шума есть можно
либо учения через научить научить можно
но гарантирует результат невозможно
научить каким-то инструмента можно она
гарантирует ну визуализации мы же
сегодня в контексте планирования говорим
да об этом обо всем и мне кажется что
визуализация и но я это наверное больше
назову как мечтание да то есть если мы
горим про планирование я всегда говорю о
том что прежде чем начать планировать и
говорить о стратегическом планировании
нужно хорошенько на мечтать то есть
чтобы поставить к это максимально
качественную большую цель нам нужно
хорошенько помечтать этот краски нам про
то говорит что сейчас горит ануар вот но
искренне убежден не держись за эту фразу
на не претендую на истину последней
станции что 1 визуализации и мечтаний
недостаточно и
вот наша сегодняшняя тема на очень важно
и мне кажется хорошо бы было погрузиться
именно вопросы планирования но еще раз
всегда планирование я лично начиная с
что не то есть нужно хорошенько не
читает про и завизировать так далее но
там уже дальше идти уже в кластеризацию
этих меч мечта недавно планирование ну
естественно в действие то есть допустим
1 dispenser это классно тоже в этом живу
кстати но скажем так искренне убежден в
том что 1 диспансер без там планирования
действий да он гардероб дают энергии g
правильного мечтания да вот если перед
правда трудно ли мы правильно мечта не я
я тоже считаю что мечта это основа надо
мечтать потом на основе мечты делать
цели на основе цели делать планы и на
основе планы делать шаги это мое личное
убеждение и я во всей этой визуализации
виду у меня своя внутренняя
местная методология основанная на моей
вере в аллаха поэтому у меня там свой
диалог свои свои молитвы и так далее но
вопрос давайте мы сейчас
уже от больших от мечтаний визуализации
перейдем к планирование вот как вы
выстраиваете свой день и вообще как
какого ваши отношения это планирование
давайте пробежимся вот так кто до какого
уровня применяет наивный вектор николаю
magalon коричную как бы для вас еще
нового не используя для меня вашу
методику то есть я не надо меня не
полностью не даю казино вот кайзен
планирование еще начинаю с этому видео
на ютюбе когда еще не начал
вот но вот кайзер планирование да то что
я практикую к стилизация дня до чтобы
вот то есть у меня не всегда получается
но с 6 до 10 этот я стараюсь чтобы это
было наше время а может могла не нашими
мое время до обеда я стараюсь делать
чтобы решать бизнес на просто так как у
меня работа связана с творчеством я
делаю так что с трех до семи это время
когда я должен у там я внутри делю но
время когда в чистом виде занимаюсь doom
его ним ну там скажем разработка
сценария идей и еще два часа я занимаюсь
таким условным редактированием дома
работа с текстом отсматриваю видео какое
то вот ну и выйти дни по моему в четверг
у меня стоит что кроме этого к этому
творчеству я отношу ищу стратегию
компании
где-то вопрос такие ну такие больше не
из них нет поставит задача просто это
время для того что думать куда мы как
ведем как извини нас насколько
планирование органично твой натуре
вообще
я просто об этом разговаривала с близким
человеком
близкие люди говорят что вообще не
органично было то есть я все таки вот
раньше был больше такой хотя я в общем
то работа в бизнесе или было больше
человеком вы знаете русский еврей д
когда вот он безумен и то есть как и как
говорят о вызывали той русские власти и
ты еврей и вот точно так же то есть
когда я работал в бизнесе я бы очень
таким творческим человеком скажем так
когда я работать творчестве теперь и
очень жесткий бизнесмену вот вот и я
думаю что планирование вообще в не был
моей сильной как бы стороны вот сейчас
она просто очень сильно как бы поменяла
я использую вот эту визуализацию но
знаете больше использовал такую от
противного то есть ну знаете никто
получает энергию от негатива ну что-то
вроде я вам еще покажу и вот на этом
пашу то есть он на каком-то таком и вот
у меня было такое вот там не были там
для от банкротства в этом просто выявить
выберусь вот те поеду в этот лас-вегас и
вот я за еду на машине с открытым верхом
как бы ибо будут гореть огни ну и потом
все это делаю как бы ну это вопрос но я
не планировал я просто на этом негативе
поставлена красота ста тысяч долларов а
теперь с этим поняв вот скажем
планирование у меня все такое на
положительных таких вещах как бы потому
что ну вот все ровным насколько это
возможно мне кажется что я еще к этому
иду таким потоком потому что есть нюансы
творческая вот работа она предполагает
форм нога я могу десяти до двух ищет все
операционные проблему вопрос задачи а
водами из трех до шести
я не могу сказать что я точно напишу по
эпизод ник ну там 16 серии потому что
может и не напишу как бы да то есть ее в
этом плане вот здесь чуть-чуть просто
якобы кости resale и но не ставлю задачу
чтобы я обязательно должен закончить
потому что она я могу закончить она но
не пойдет не соответствует
вот поэтому я думаю что у меня прям
вообще произошел появилась у него ним то
есть я буквально планирую там скользим
планирование уже больше года я прямо
на канат
вот когда я жила шри-ланки я вообще был
против планов ну то есть при мне был
такой пост потому что все что я планирую
жизнь ничего не не сглазь в итоге да
когда jet cool даже не планировался
потом выяснилось что все-таки
подсознательно я хотел 3 приехать видимо
это тоже сыграло свою роль но
потом вернулся в констант и я понял что
нужно в этой агрессивной среде нужно
все-таки во времени как ориентироваться
из договориться с очень многими людьми
тогда я начал заново планировать и куплю
себе книжку 6 минут называется не
слишком это прям вот почему шесть минут
тут как раз таки затем записали теперь
записываем 6 минут вот это для тех кто
думал что планировать так долго это
нужно съесть прямо так все записать на
это уходит 6 минут реально и
важно просто приоритетной задачей
выделить две приоритетные задачи в день
одну супер проявить это и 2к бы одна из
них как бы она потом выходит 2
приоритетные и там 5 уже не приоритетных
какие-то лайтовый потому что человек за
день качественно может только от двух до
трех задача сделать качественно я не
говорю о том что распылиться при этом не
перегореть не перегорел вот там есть
такой месячный план что я хотел бы
сделать их ежедневный но во всем этом я
понял что важно
быть в какой-то в балансе каком-то то
есть не уходить в планы вот и держаться
за него да вот не бесят такие люди когда
ты работаешь в
команде уже запланировали туда в
такую-то денег ну слушай ну не
получается или погода не та пандемий а в
конце концов там что-то в коллектив ну
вот и семь пятниц на неделе нет это не
75 это умение импровизировать чтобы
сейчас выбраться ситуация на мои сейчас
нам не до просто не случайно себя надел
чтобы не забудьте сказать
шахматисты до этого наверное из всех
интеллектуальных спорта это те кто
далеко планирует да вот именно в игре и
гарри каспарова задали вопрос насколько
вперед ходов вы думаете сколько перед
планируете но он ответил в принципе
можно на 13-15 ходов вперед продумать но
я этого не делаю потому что это миллиону
вариантов ты перед пока их про думаешь
ты потеряешь на этом сил и я
я просто смотрю на текущую позицию делаю
лучший ход сейчас потому что с каждым
ходом там миллионы вариантов до
комбинации и ты все-равно теряешь на
этом время чтобы ты гордо видишь я
сделаю этот ход и какие могут быть
последствия здесь но есть обязательно
стратегия обязательно стратегия нужно но
не нужно придерживаться чётких каких-то
вот якорей куда я пришел такой все сидят
на может и не добежишь может быть ты
обойдешь его вариантов может быть много
поэтому я задавалась когда можно быть
гибким а гибкость это значит ты не
ломаешься и ты всегда можешь лавировать
то есть ну никита на жизнь в принципе
организованный хаос да поэтому в этом
организован хаусе тоже нужно быть и
хаотичным и организован в том числе
такой некий танец как ты знаешь что-то
вы твой противник в виде твоей кого-то
проблемы сложности ты должен тоже с ней
станцевать есть способ бороться драться
но в танце стиль айкидо ты решаешь это
проще чем
удивить вы я я не был удивлен
я же как раз таки сибарит я очень люблю
себя и очень себе жалею да то есть
поэтому у меня нету никаких долгосрочных
планов я все планирую в краткосрочный
период пользуясь обычным гугл календарь
он мне не нужен тайм-менеджмент мне не
нужен контент в этой в этом это при моей
жизни то есть я исхожу из удовольствия
которые мне приносит то чем я занимаюсь
и по этому в принципе
я никогда не
выделяю обед допустим для работы то есть
обед это время друзей и никак более
ничем нельзя занимать обед если мне
куда-то надо я могу перекроить планы в
две секунды но я никогда не подвожу
людей по обязательствам я всегда приеду
во время если пообещал согласился и то
есть но
самоваром я согласен в том плане что и в
моем окружении есть много людей которые
хотят
строго по бюджету двигается и строго по
плану то есть я понимаю что ну жизнь
преподносит столько сюрпризов что ну
невозможно все вот как планировалось
сделать и в этом отношении там стиль
айкидо мне тоже подходит потому что я
могу резко все поменять но при этом
стараясь не подводить людей по
обязательствам вот в принципе и все то
есть я все-таки за
сибарит 2 то есть я не изнасилование
себя просто потому что вот это надо да
то есть я свою жизнь организовал так что
как бы у меня остается время на пожалеть
себя если я ну заработался немножко есть
время для того чтобы но я еще и а врач
то есть если я там не нужно прочитать
тренинг там крупные компании они
договаривались за два месяца я все равно
все сделаю в последний момент ну то есть
последнюю ночь сяду и кстати неплохо
выступают потом то есть я вот как бы не
умею подготовить его за в неделю и потом
вы полтора месяца вообще не напрягаться
по поводу того что у тебя выступление
готова уже на кураже то есть можно
сказать что совсем без планирования не
ну что значит совсем без планирования
гугл календарь отличный планировщик то
есть какие-то общие встреча
долгосрочного планирование нет то есть
то я не знаю чем я буду заниматься на
пенсии да то есть я не знаю чем и
занимается буду там через пять лет а но
при этом у меня есть я знаю чем я буду
ближайший год занят да то есть у меня
есть планы на 2022 я примерно по месяцу
у меня где-то до сентября все расписано
то есть мужчин зафиксировать что без
детального плана тоже можно быть
успешным и добиваться на творчество ну
того-то и подразумевает
когда ты как сложить и я как
предприниматель вот у меня есть задачи
по работе я заработано то развиваю
проекты поэтому я ставлю утром выделяю
некий к 1 час до я ставлю 3 задачи по
работе такие основные задачи вот как он
ведь
помимо этого есть две задачи по
личностному развитию это ну допустим там
изучение английского языка утром и вот
эта встреча это тоже как по личностному
развитию еще стоит ее жесткие
встряхивают как или шериф калли дарят
уже обязательно фиксе да потому что он
знает игры со с людьми надо
зафиксировать именно в это время
остальные они гибкие ту стену когда хочу
к ним подхожу на камеру этом время обеда
я лучше поедем и потом сделаю стараюсь
гибко подходить
ваши методологии от показан планированию
очень хорошо подходит и одну очень такую
важную вещь учитывал при планировании к
это задача раскидываю он тоже очень
важно про внутреннюю энергетику
нельзя ну как бы стараясь не ставить
задачи друг за другом которые забирают
энергию стараюсь чередовать их вот
допустим если две такие задачи которые
нужно прям вот силу воли про и видит вот
себя заставить людей сделать то
обязательно там либо какой-то отдых либо
но надо что то такое что что добавляет
энакином вот тоже очень важный момент у
вас случился у нас на но главное хорошо
ты это применяешь и сформулировал а к
норман я бы наверное разделил вообще
выпуска клонирования в своей жизни на
три части раньше вообще не планировал то
есть в принципе не знал что это такое и
жил как то вот как-то жил до но в тот
момент у меня как-то все и получалось
вот как-то жил как то все получалось на
самом деле каких-то твердых результатов
не было вообще а потом в какой-то момент
стал больше думать наверное не про
тактическое и операционное планирование
до больше про стратегическое то о чем мы
сейчас говорили то мечтать и все
остальное да и в какой-то момент у меня
уже с вами ask это идеальное видение
будущего где бы я хотел оказаться там
условно сплясать на столетие своей
любимой супруги и и общем от этого все
пошло как я к этому бы пришел и начал
какими-то там крупными мазками
делить это идеальное видение и
в конечном итоге это все приехала к тому
что у меня есть задача ключевые кем бы я
хотел стать через 10 лет
дасти раньше для меня шаг был там год
теперь там 10 и я дам даже в прошлом
году до 2 июня на написал на листочке а4
значит цели все это там упаковал в
бутылку
пробочка с ургу что все дела и увез на
землю предков на 10 лет пусть полежит да
я в это искренне верю это моя там
эзотерика это наса даже не эзотерика это
внутренний душевный порыв
момент пандемии не смог ввести двадцатом
году двадцать первом году 22 июня мы это
сделали
простуда
определенная карты обязательства перед
данным что ты еще и затем предков у вас
отыщем увидал этому надо такое ну на
самом деле как бы кто как рассматривает
ну для меня это тоже некий элемент
планирования с ног к этому все подвожу
потому что оттуда теперь строится вся
моя жизнь то есть губа это эти задачи
есть промежуточная цель между моим
великим далеким будущем где я наверное
уже будет там условно даже уже не
стареющая увядающей нибудь там . в
отличие от
[музыка]
разделил свою жизнь на
четыре года жил в 4 линиях жизни то есть
задумался четыре года назад на тему того
что для меня самое главное потому что
все и сразу планировать было невозможно
да и 2018 году мне даже есть выступление
в круг оси где я там заявил что вот
теперь там моей жизни будет там
кластеризация я берусь только за четыре
линии жизни у это было здоровье энергия
одолеть развитие этом интеллектуальная
духовная культурное развитие именно
третье это было отношение с собой с
близкими людьми с окружающим миром
отношения и 4 это карьера бизнес финансы
и вот разделил жизнь на четыре кластера
и мне так легче планировать то есть я
планирую по каждой линии жизни отдельно
тыс губа у меня есть там время для
планирования одну или не жизни 2 3 4
самое главное допустим для меня вот в
элементе планирования что я поставлю во
главу угла потому что все-таки в каждой
линии жизни что-то должно быть каким-то
таким вот но главное фундаментальная не
тогда это было гармоничное развитие
потому что до этого у меня был
негативный опыт жизненный да когда я там
упирался в одну ну допустим там финансы
да у меня другие линии жизни страдали у
пульс в отношения у меня эти линии жизни
начинают провисать я поставил во главу
угла именно гармоничное развитие то есть
как бы так чтобы все линии жизни
развивались одновременно мы даже есть на
эту тему метафора про там стол и четыре
ножки что каждая линия жизни до ножка
есть я хочу допустим сделать из 10
условно финансах она на все об этом
мечтают этом приумножится и все
остальное в благости
то мне нужно развивать одновременно все
остальные линии жизни а без планирования
это ваще пну для меня это было уже
невозможно что нужно было как бы так и я
стал для себя состоятся ли там каждый
год но во главе угла было именно вот эта
гармония и вот за четыре года слава богу
мне удалось это сделать но там нужно
было уже разделить там цели год там
полугодие квартал месяц неделя
и потом я пришел ко дню да и есть и бери
там про гармоничное развитие то у меня
день должен был выглядеть таким образом
чтобы в этом да не было время для себя
отношения смысле развитие и точнее потом
там для работы для бизнеса карьеры
финансов для отношений там собой с
близкими людьми и для здоровья энергии
долголетия ну и как бы это все пришло к
тому что за четыре года у меня
сформировались некий привычки то есть
изначально это было планирование я до
вначале было немножко некомфортно это
исполнять а на сегодняшний день это
превратилось тупо в привычке то есть вот
какие то и дневной привычки и в моем
допустим лично планирование было так что
я скажу так в моменте оставил только
одну цель на сегодня если там в
саморазвитии блин давать так скажу у
меня день 9 утра с 6 до 8 у меня время
для себя для саморазвития с 8 до 18
время для бизнеса карьеры и финансов с
18 до 21 до 22 это время для отношений
там у меня родные и близкие друзья и 22
и отбой это для здоровья
естественному три дня много всего так
пласти резерва и
если допустим у меня время для
саморазвития с утратой я ставлю одну
цель в последнее время маргулан к речь
будет там очень много времени занимаете
вот именно они на самом деле я посмотрю
сейчас
вашу платформу и уже по второму разу
изучаю вот и по третьему разу уже буду
прям конспектировать и забирать для себя
все лучше и потому что следующий на
следующий год то есть поставил для себя
во главу угла некий level up да то есть
это четыре года у меня было гармоничное
развитие а теперь гармоничные level up
да и вот тут вопрос да что нужно сделать
я сделал ревизию всех цельный мечтаний
оттуда потом сделал ревизию цели
десятилетних и на самом деле знаете это
же тоже некий элемент планирования если
вдруг получилось бы так что та цель
которую загадал себе там полтора два
года назад стала бы неактуальной я
согласен анвар я бы отменил вообще даже
без без зазрения совести я бы сказал не
бывает такая да то есть ты планировал
себе одно прошло время и вот в жизни
произошло много перемен даже на самом
деле не внешних а внутренний что эти
цели они тебе уже и не нужны и зачем
планировать скажем так ну вот могла
кричи вы вчера говори да там многие люди
там по пути пройдут пойму что цель не
актуально и все равно полпути доходят
для того чтобы просто выполню не усадьба
что есть горлач зачем им нужно это же не
для этого нужно ну по сути я всегда себе
задаю вопрос а зачем мне нужно это
планирование
для того чтобы будь счастливым что
планирование это же некий элемент
эффективности и да и вот если говорить
там про меня нынешнего то на двадцать
второй год ну так гармонично или вала
что я хочу я хочу чтобы моя жизнь вышла
на некий скажем так новый уровень и
сделала это так не этом ст ибо если я
пока ты в лифт зайти нажать на кнопочку
там и слон куда десятого этажа и
быстренько подняться и
начал с ревизией тех больших целей все
там нормально спустился к линиям жизни
понял что первая глава лап для себя хочу
сделать в количестве линии жизни потому
что условно четырьмя шариками научился
жонглировать и добавил еще два то есть
сейчас добавляется у меня хобби и
увлечение развлечений от чего я
умышленно отказался 2016 году когда вот
на чем планированием серьезное маца и
добавил еще честно деятельности
благодарить а что за ходом можно от
которого отказались и возвращайтесь а у
них еще не было то есть я знаю что
теперь занимался не увлечение не
различением никак не для меня было
открытие вот я веду группу
наставничество для меня открытие было
что у некоторых ребят нет не существует
ходы как такое может быть в принципе для
меня это несовместимо в моем моей голове
если говорить про планировали кстати
немало я посвящаю очень много времени
планирование размышлению и когда дело в
том что вы все что вы говорите вы все
правы просто надо смотреть такую вещь
есть жесткая система планирования когда
цель и фиксированные задачи
фиксированные срок эффективны это
покажет в американских фильмах вот
дьявол носит prada там все поминутно
ассистенты бегают всех стрессе шеф такой
супер супер организованной но это
неправда это для чистая для фильмов миф
есть
гибкая система планирования когда цели
фиксированным а задачи и сроки
выполнения могут меняться и 99 проснусь
людей вот живут в этой парадигме
но я использую динамическую систему
планирования это когда ты можешь менять
как целей так и задачи такие сроки
почему потому что я вот он упомянул
бывает люди вот так 50 км пути пройдут и
добивает последние 50 процентов потому
что нужно так называем закрытием
гештальт я говорил это знаете напоминает
как в бухучёт есть такое понятие fit for
rivals фифа этот first things first
олифа нас think fast test это управление
складом до или привожу для налоги что
проще было блины и
опадали блин ты кушаешь
не половину съел 2 разве ж блин пришел
ты говоришь я не буду его трогать пока
не 7 и 3 доедаешь этот блин в это время
потом берешь этот блин пришел свежие ты
опять внешних свежий выждать томился не
свежими блинами это называется фифа
соответственно люди которые преследуют
такую цель то они все время приследуют
неактуальную цель потому что пока не
добьют в это время не добиваются
актуальные цели и все время не как
собака за хвостом гоняются за
неактуальными целями поэтому моя задача
такая горка динамическая система
планирования ты должен каждый день ariag
анализировать все свои цели каждый день
цели должны быть но ты должен каждый
говорит сегодня на меня давит или нет
потому что иначе ты будешь все время
преследовать цель вчерашнего себя
месячного назад себя годового назад себя
от и сейчас изменился в у тебя там 90
процентов клеток меня из этом за сколько
пару дней от уже другая наверно сам а ты
продолжаешь цели того ануар и который
может вообще понять и другие были другие
интересы были поэтому это называется
динамическое планирование и это никак не
противоречит вот тому что вы говорите
творческая там я могу отменить цель-то
если она не актуально надо менять и тает
в динамике систем планирования на прям
таки по 2 смотр а как ты можешь понять
вот ну то есть как бы пример который вы
приводите очень похож на то у
нас было 10 человек мы выиграли все
гранты и в один из престижных
университетов казахстана то есть и где
там наверное на первый год обучение мы
поняли о том что нет ну то есть это не
совсем то что нам дает и это не очень
качественное не очень хорошо вот и 7 и
10 они бросили
я из-за того что международная
организация дала грант оплатила мне его
и все стану я следующий год просто вот
довел его до конца отзыв для того чтобы
закрыть де сталь но вопрос уже в том что
я же на тот момент в 22 года не понимал
пригодится мне это в будущем или нет и
как будто это умение доводить до конца
мне кажется это хорошая была черта
потому что сейчас вы говорите надо было
бросались я сразу объясню это
такой прием применяется в инвестировании
я одно из правил и инвестирование говорю
вот ко мне приходят ребята и говорят я
хочу продать вот этого и
зачем он
говорит ну что вы выйти в кэш и вы зачем
ну как в кэш но йогурт в каши не усидишь
ты захочешь а также инвестировать ну да
я брал тебя есть куда инвестировать нет
а тогда зачем выходишь то есть смысл
такой ты говоришь про одну часть
процесса то есть выйти то есть бросить
универ бросать университет надо было
тогда когда у тебя в руках есть
альтернатива лучше чем бросать вынужден
а просто бросить университет потом часа
требует думать о колледже жить но это
глупость и в этом плане постольку
поскольку у тебя не было альтернативы
лучше темнее
ты правильно сделал ты добил университет
потому что это не было альтернатив лучше
а если бы у человека была такая версия
вот добивать мушкет либо его пригласили
работать в apple и компании понятно он
бросил вещества переходят сюда это
правильно решили и здесь вопрос просто
так бросать нельзя цель бросать цель
можно только в том случае мы людей у
тебя есть потому что смотри ты идешь
какой-то цели она перестала кедра я ведь
и
так же я ее брошу подожди ноуте
альтернативы нет хорошо 1000 бросишься
нужно делать варят или сериалы смотреть
отвердел пока другого нету поэтому пока
продолжай пока продолжает все-таки твоя
старая цель лучше чем вообще отсутствие
цели и в этом плане вот если брать про
шахматы кстати
гарри каспаров конечно чувак о чугунный
но он как любой профессионал
недоговаривает какие-то вещи которые для
него является само собой разумеющимся як
шахматам так как я бывший президент
федерации шахмат и ок шахматам подходил
как чисто как бизнесмен и об шахмат
плохо играю поэтому мне нужно было очень
быстро научиться шахматам и понять суть
игры я подумал блин это сколько ходов
перед надо просчитывать и когда я так
думал я понимал что это тупику путь
нельзя шаги вперёд тогда я подумал так
шахматов 64 фигуры
64 фигуры красная 4s 64 клетки и занять
до 30 фигуры значит каждая фигура
определяет не имеет свое определенное
огневую мощь который выражается в
количестве клеток значит моя задача
создать на доске такую ситуацию при
котором каждая моя фигура покрывает
максимально возможное количество клеток
это кстати не мой ноу-хау это потом я я
начал в этом плане думать девятнадцатом
веке был спросил таким пули мне об этом
рассказал да я посмотреть у меня я в чем
моя заслуга я начал искать путь что не
должно быть в количестве ходов наперёд
секрет должен быть всегда должны быть
другом и начал изучать
мастера спорта по шахматам я гуру хотя
на это невозможно чтобы шаги вперед я
говорю вот по идее тоже по математике
вот так рассказать так
и для меня это было такое открытие что
есть тридцать две фигуры можно находить
такую точку выстраивает при котором твоя
фигура бьет на и максимальное количество
полей это первое а это как правило
середины шахматной доски соответствует
выстроишь стратегию такую что вот связан
быстро захватить центр максимально
быстро развернуть фигурой
соответственно и в каждой шахматной
позиции есть точно такие же вещи с
говорим про стратегию
ский план в начале тебе захватить центр
это это не это не то что план
стратегически это принцип твоя каждый
мой должна быть максимально коли спалила
на и в дебюте и в эндшпиле одинаково
очень каждая фигура должна бить маленько
резилин
второе ты должен максимально развернуть
свои фигуры чтобы они не били друг друга
то есть это та же это такие принципы это
не стратегия стратегии это когда есть
цель ты достигаешь есть да данная
стратегия низ ближняя тактика и так
далее поэтому в этом плане я считаю что
dice больше наверно
неправильная интерпретация планирования
планируем если вы используете
динамическое планирование есть и вы
имеете правильные вообще базовые прочь
подходы к этому делу то планерный
работает на самом деле просто суперские
эффективно еще мтс уже у меня есть на
платформе и урок называется
эффективность так вот легитимности
говорится что любой инструмент и
эффективным тогда когда ты не замечаешь
его работа
так вот хорошие планирование если ты его
внедришь ты даже не буду чувствовать то
есть он никогда теперь хорошее понимание
даже даже не может нет для тебя
нормально потому что вода а ты не
чувствуешь на планерной второе ты
удовлетворён теми результатами которые
мы тебе дают все это два основных
критерия для любого планирование
проблема же в том что когда можно ли его
лопнуть ты перестаешь дуэль
удовлетворяться результатом тогда ты уже
начинаешь внедрять что-то новое которые
начали может быть не комфортно можно я
продолжу могла конечно теперь бью я не
закончил свой
[смех]
я к чему-то суета вел к тому что сейчас
когда хочу на главный дар передо мной
встал вопрос что-то систему планирования
которые я использовал да то есть там
было только стратегическое планирование
была только одна задача там один день
она уже неактуально то есть ею но скажем
так вижу что она реально не актуально
почему я зашел на платформу почему зашел
наставничеством что мне нужны
инструменты и вот в этом на этой
платформе я сейчас нахожу реальный ответ
на вопрос но вы уже так скажем
предвосхитили опередили да я хотел об
этом сказать что понимаю что на старте
мне сейчас скорее всего будет не
комфортно внедрять новую систему
планирования они но я уже вижу что где
то там на финише где-то может
год-два-три да она для меня станет
нормой и перестанут также чувствуется
сейчас то есть спокойно будет
жонглировать там шестью шарами и выйду
ну уверенно тесто 9 9 да что вы до на
новый уровень жизни и к вопросу о
планирования тут наверное вот больше
вопрос не что я буду делать а зачем я
это делаю эту землю бы запрете на
вопросами зачем что если нету смысла в
том что я делаю но и вообще смысл это
делать я понимаю что именно вот вопрос
планирования и внедрения его в жизнь
свою подарит мне скажем так инструменты
эффективности которых вы уже сказали то
есть это за меньшее количество ресурсов
достигать большие результаты то есть
эффективно же это про н то есть и он мне
позволит меньшим количеством ресурсов
достигать больших результатов грубо если
мне было четыре линии жизни дай на
работу меня было там 10 часов то теперь
внедряя 6 линии жизни у меня на работу
будет ну условно там 8 часов может 6
часов да еще в идеале мы 5 часов до в
день там и в неделю скот не я иду в
японии дачами и мне хочется привод
уменьшение количества времени которые я
буду инвестировать в работы теперь
увеличить количество результате
увеличивать количество результатов а тут
про эффективность им бесплатно на мой
взгляд без планирования без какой-то
системы планирования
оплата будет сложнее можно уверен
можно то сделать но все-таки верит что с
эти местом а вот смотрите теперь такой
момент хорошо планерное более менее все
как в той или иной форме применяет
давайте поговорим есть ли вообще минусы
планирования давайте поговорим в этот
раз про все минусы которые планировали
вот никого у тебя как ну вот вопрос вот
этой самой импровизации до которое
возникает очень резко
наверное стоит сейчас так я об этом не
думал потому что я пока еще нахожусь в
их арене и от как сказать самого
планирования потому что долго время
этого не делал вот моя то с чем я
сталкиваюсь это то что ну забивая
событиями и глубоко график куда их можно
наверно передвинуть но как бы
как сказать вы для меня как мне кажется
вот колечко парте меня вот когда ты вот
сидишь и думаешь какое какой лучше
делать делать да там он это какие-то
условно к потере что ли какие-то ту же
энергетически ну то есть пока дискомфорт
от того что какие-то события могут
возникать внезапно ну например вчера у
нас была встреча я думаю она будет до
8 8 она была до 10 я вот там рядовой до
часа сидели до длится до часа сидели и я
как-то вот когда нужны только тогда я
ушел но я немножко уже в этот момент
потому что у меня в 10 там тоже станет
какие-то дела наверное если бы этого
дела боли не связанные с другими людьми
я бы их спокойно как бы переложил у нас
прям и то есть на там видно из кластер
потому что перекинуть но так как это
было связано с другими людьми да как бы
вот может быть в этом что импровизации
как бы как будто меньше время становится
плотнее 0 если это можно назвать минусом
ну то есть просто 2 ваше время в том
числе куча личные там дела она когда все
становится таким как расписанным но
опять-таки могу теорем медный обыскал
такой праве зация переходит из
сиюминутной импровизации в долгосрочный
то есть когда ты планируешь вперед
импровизируешь но на перёд а когда-то
нет по нервным ты все время должны
реагировать да вот вот это есть это же
незнакомое я просто вот продолжаем если
колли о том что люди которые привыкают
все планировать им очень тяжело
перестроиться к хаосу то есть на условно
говоря для наших родителей то развивал
свои адского союза безусловно то есть
когда вся жизнь была распланирована
и появилось огромное количество людей
которые не вписались в рыночные
отношения потеряли себя то есть я знаю
огромное количество взрослых людей я
знаю там например поменьше это пандемия
которая случилась безусловно для рынка
это черный лебедь потому что
вроде как никто кроме билла гейтса
пандемию не ожидал да то есть и все что
случилось в людей по рушились планы
работы и все остальное я могу сказать
что поехала крыша у огромного количества
людей то есть это люди которые
планировали они четко знали какой цели
они идут и тут появляется какой-то вирус
который полностью уничтожает все их
мечты и планы там даже на ближайшее
время и как бы если посмотреть там на
моего психотерапевта братом у нее все
забито и это огромное количество людей я
думал ты скажи
наоборот у нее увеличилось количество
клиентов мужчин который и вот реально не
вписались пост пандемию да то есть они
не смогли справиться с теми be some
которые безусловно в них были но за счет
того что как то они могли
спрогнозировать свое ближайшее будущее у
них видимо все было нормально но
пандемия и загнанный и там в дома в
квартиры люди вдруг начали сходить с ума
и это вот ну как бы одна из тех вещей
где наша спонтанной ну то есть например
ну пандемий а ну окей ну давайте жить
дальше и сложившихся условиях да то есть
мы просто быстрее стану сам на новые
рельсы она напоминаешь ты сейчас
говоришь про гибку и жесткую стен
динамическая система планировать такая
ну пандемию убиваем новые планы на самом
деле это многие придерживаются по из
томате что ты запланировал день за
месяц до и усуи живите
здесь основная проблема в том что люди
становятся рабами вот как планирование
metal gear рабом человека кто через
верно
хотел сказать тоже
десятилетий минус планирования я его ног
многие зрители тоже как планирует многие
люди планируют таким образом что создают
в туда листья большой список большой
список дел на там сильно нужна дела-то
нужные задачи нужно решать жизненно
важные по работе и личностные по
развитию но он не такой гибкий как мы
сейчас это привыкли видеть этом виде
канбан доски а это виде туду листа этот
улисс но я на себе я помню когда я вел
такой монизма канбан вы вообще нормально
[смех]
нормально тоже
не сделал на русском хотя бы на
список дел на
[смех]
платформе очень доходчиво объясняю
напрягаемся какую-то платформу друзьям и
какая то есть платформа морган коля
на самом деле многие подумают
прогревом
платформа друзьям и дизель
ни в коем случае это не для науки
посвящу
унизили друзья мы с вами решение
просвещенная
итак когда есть большой список дел и
бывает моменты когда дела не выполнять
только копится как быстро мы купим дела
мы уже знаем да в течение дня там
пролетает что такие то новые задачи
быстро очень выполняется и медленно
выполняются при задача в результате мы
имеем огромный список которые просто да
мало того что там задач они
рассортированы так они еще и разные по
объему по-своему
позвонить даттон какой-то большой проект
это вот большой кашля очень сильно давит
сверху и помню от ловил себя на мысли
отдыхали семьей в дебатах примеру я не
мог сосредоточиться в моменте да вот
хотя я проводил время сидит наоборот
казалось предложен отдохнуть
отдохнуть от работы нет мыслями как
будто я на работе нахожусь какую-то
будто есть какие-то задачи или упущенные
возможности которыми ему пробегают а я
тут семью и как бы ни казалось куча
задачам не ждет на работе а я здесь хотя
сегодня выходной и это очень сильно
мешает а на работе наоборот вы думаешь
про семью и обвес немало времени провожу
и вот и это все результат того что ну
как я думаю задача не рассортировано
во-первых да то есть они в одной кучке
во вторых они не поделен и по на
приоритетности то есть мелкие там
позвонить одношаговый задачи у больших
проектов тоже нужно грамотно планировать
ну ты сейчас говоришь про минусы
планирования в виде тут у глистах то
есть с одной стороны поднял этот вопрос
как раз давайте поговорим о минусах
планирования и это я считаю некорректным
вопрос потому что
минусов нам нужно четко понимать какого
планирования до минуса и какого
планирования поэтому нужно это четко
понимать а с другой стороны смотрите
давайте еще такую вещь мы обсуждаем
планирование и управление энергией вот
это очень важный момент потому что
планировать вы можете что угодно сколько
угодно как модно ставить цели но если у
вас не будет энергии вы нифига ничего
нигде сделать кстати в к этим
планирование как раз сегодня чингиз тоже
упоминал ли нурлан что очень важно в
процессе выполнения дел не забывать еще
смотреть на свой бензобак это как ты на
своем пикапе едешь возит сено там дрова
и так далее но на бензобаке должен все
время смотреть и исходить из этого
потому что это не вопрос и мир и еще
очень важный момент к нам очень много
приходят то ребят
полностью выгоревшей вот то что ты
говоришь после пандемия есть просто меня
нет энергии у них апатии
пожизненного фрустрация джинсы силы и
так далее вот давайте поговорим о
управлению энергией как вы
обращали на это внимание
мы будем поливать
почему хочу забрать микрофон в эту
сторону потому что в данный момент
проживает такой момент когда
просто энергия пошла вниз и
вот для меня допустим динамической
системы планирования когда я могу
полностью окунуться и планы тактические
операционные да понятно что
стратегические цели tamiya на них
посмотрел они все нормально ними не
откликаются заряжают энергией то есть
вот отправил свой дискетку там с этим на
самом деле всего три пункта просто может
быть кто то подумает что типа из серии
там вещества и списал 10 том не засунула
в бутылку и увез на землю предков нет
там всего три очень простые вообще там
фразой когда-нибудь я их разверну
надеюсь там не достигну через действие
оставлю с не достигну через 20 основания
не на 30 что у меня из там принципе с не
достиг цели срок то меняй срока не цель
если она все-таки твоя и сейчас когда
начал проживать упадок энергии очень
важно не доводить это выгорание
стопроцентно и здесь как бы вопрос
планирование да на мой взгляд он не
должен быть настолько жестким что типа
нет не надо выполнить все планы у меня
задачей потому что потому что это такой
раз выигрывал и сдох это ложь и замены
то есть не модниц я все-таки за то чтобы
подумать аж почему я выгорают и иметь
возможность все-таки эти планы
пересмотреть настолько чтобы дать себе
возможность выспаться то есть у меня
есть и там упадок я сразу первая вода и
да да отношения и выспаться то есть я
всегда делают курильщикам чем я смогу
нормально съедают нормально с
отношениями нормально значит у повысился
и вот несколько дней со льдом
возможность 2 возможно высыпаться просто
вот те которые даже задачи стояли передо
мной этот вопрос приоритетов
если там скажем так приоритет все-таки
энергия у меня энергия то я перед игры
сникерса все люди все могут понять да
можно передоговориться какие-то там
встречи там перекинуть на после обеда и
просто до обеда поспать несколько дней
до семьей договориться у меня получилось
и энергии пришла обратно в обратное
русло я к чему это все говорю потому что
искренне убежден в том что планирование
должны быть настолько жестким что даже
если у тебя батарейка уже все падает
вновь и ты всюду привычка поэтому я был
недавно на на
комикконе к не фирме женщина рассказал
про разные породы лошадей по
чем здесь в моде и она горит что
по-моему казахской она там вот наша
порода лошадей
и десна лошадь которую не загонишь
смерть то есть
я устала и пока меня не на boite не
дадите отдохнуть я никуда не убегу то
есть не то что nude как нам людям доска
с вопросам планирования нужно быть очень
аккуратными если вдруг так получается
что мы уже там сами себя загоняем что
все-таки ставить скажем так энергию и
себя приоритет всем этим планом и давать
ну то есть планирование должно быть
настолько динамическим чтобы его можно
было немножко отодвинуть и поставить
себя придет что если мы себя загоним и
зайдём вот в эту историю там уже нам
планирование модно вы искренне убежден
этом я извиняюсь у меня сегодня мы
просто жизнь у меня позвали этом на 1
мероприятие но я почувствовал
ненормально энергетически споем и дальше
приду подержу ночи хочу найти
потому что не хочу
я ж не знал то что и уставлен еще по
этому поводу
я о чем в почему у людей появляется
прокрастинация ли не желание что-то
делать это все на самом деле подсознании
использовать как инструмент и удержания
нашей энергии чтобы мы не потрать мере
соответственно мы теряем энерго почему
потому что первое а
это то что мы не видим смысла
первое потеря смысла сразу лишает нас
все мотивации энергии поэтому смотри
энергия дается под смысл есть смысл
что-то сделать для тебя есть смысл ты
найдешь энергию найдешь она появится
поехали понять из данного как заново
родился поэтому он упадет
расстроился расстроился так вот смотрите
уже фаворите верный самый сильный
демотиватор или решительной энергии
второе это когда ты не выспался михаил
там не отдохнул и так далее поэтому
здесь вопрос такой когда ты говоришь не
хочу идти это явно показательно что у
тебя просто нету смысла и когда у тебя
нету смысла у тебя включается лень
прокрастинация и куча отмазок вот вновь
начинает для этого обосновывать и
находите тысячу грамотных причин почему
ты не должен это сделать или почему ты
не смог это сделать так вот по надейся
на свой мозг и ты найдешь отмазки почему
ты не сможешь сегодня пойти туда и либо
завтра объясниться почему ты не смог
прийти
придумаешь этот человек мозг у нас в
этом плане профессионалов и сейчас к
взрывам писатели тату ты захочешь
но с другой стороны вот задача в чем
заключается твоя тыс а вот на этом
поймал что дал обещание и сегодня не
захотел идти до просто сделать следующий
раз а вот алгоритм .
как поступать в таких случаях когда мне
приносил тот человек который которым я
не могу отказать
просто алгоритм
я добавлю очень вас ты слишком голода
проговорить ранено платформа отсутствие
энергии
есть еще и чисто медицинское обоснование
этому поэтому в первую очередь как фанат
традиционной медицины сдайте анализы
сходите к эндокринологу
проверьтесь это может быть симптомы
каких-либо заболеваний
эндокринной системы нервной системой и
после этого можете воспользоваться ну
как бы другими восполнить или рекламное
по цене нет никого рекламе индикатор я
просто о том что иногда люди не понимают
почему они устают да то есть это бывает
просто недостатка кого-то витамины и 1 и
еще другая скажу дело в том что все
медики говорят чтобы все болезни от
нервов а
почему нервы напрягается
незакрытые гештальты не выполненные дела
невыполненные обязательства
когда ты занимаешься делом которым не
имеет смысла и так далее так далее
поэтому если брать долгосрочную причину
то все на самом деле идет от внутреннего
несогласие с тем что ты делаешь от того
что ты не видишь смысла когда человек
имеет процесс но не но имеют процесс но
не имеет результата это называется
сизифов труд и это только вопрос времени
когда он заболеет кадра мир вы заболеете
так далее
психосоматика как еще говорят поэтому да
за особо запущенных случаях это конечно
медицинский
случай но чтобы не доводить до
медицинского случая и постепенно
выходить то я считаю вот поправления
нами как раз тот случай ну и потом я по
одним из первых это понял да то есть про
управление энергии просто потому что мне
в отличие от короткой шеей нужно чуть
больше уже иметь еду на меня посмотрели
тоже вам гораздо легче вставать с
постели чем мне был утром что вы встаете
на уровне
метра 50 я встаю на 204 поймите это вот
сам рычаг тяжелее да я ношу 130
килограммов до себе хотя никто не видит
этот 30 до
и ты хочешь понимаешь их друг тушу
таскаешь на себе да то есть это очень
тяжело это всегда нагрузка увеличены
одни автомобилей не самолеты ничего под
нас не приспособленное чтобы вы понимали
именно поэтому для нас энергия играет
большее значение нам просто тяжелее
вставать война или больше времени трачу
на отдых на то что я могу срубить вот в
любой момент я отказываюсь 90 процентов
участия мероприятия не это очень легко
ребят не могу все извините я не хожу
между светской жизнью не хожу куда-либо
я изначально сам по себе это понял из-за
комплект комплекции что нужно больше
времени проводить там где тебе нравится
в постели допустим можно психосоматику
двумя фразами сейчас с ней все
проще вассал я просто вы говорите как
фанат как традиционная медицина да я как
практик и медицина скажи что-то можно
погрузиться в клеточную
там сейчас медицина но
психосоматика это просто вот отрицание
внутренние того что нахожусь не там где
хочу и делать не то что хочу то есть
грубо вот две фразы да и то если сейчас
все это там сложить в кучу и ожидание
реальность дан ожидания малыша не с кем
хочу
пару слов пару слов про энергетику да
вот мы говорим и часто люди воспринимают
то что мы говорим про энергетику важно
следить за ней важно иметь высокий
уровень не тратить попусту энергию ну
это воспринимается да да в этом знаем
энергию надо тратить да да там на
хорошее но тем не менее остаются
какие-то такие вещи которые очень
сильного через которые очень сильно
выходит именно энергетика и потом не
хватает уже ее ну на те же самые
согласиться и так корпоративы
превышение
сейчас про что речь я очень сейчас за
собой спешу и
[музыка]
заметил что есть такие вещи как что-то
типа на эти обиды или там острые какие
то возможны конфликтные ситуации
когда ты не успел среагировать и да не
успел среагировать что там когда
конфликтной ситуации на дороге то
бытовой случае бывает и вот буквально
хорошее настроение было дочурки ехала
тут раз и к буквально секунды не минут и
после этого уже плохое все и ты потерял
эту энергию большой кусок отдал надолго
на блин долго да у меня почему-то у меня
не бывает надолго особенность у дороги и
дадите открытость
очень много смотрите по поводу
обида и потерь энергии действительно
обиду очень сильно забирают энергию ну
если брать что такое обиды отбиты это не
оправданные
ожидания поэтому у меня даже когда и
баги турвизу всегда гур ребята мне целая
наука есть называется менеджмент
ожидании управления ожиданиям или
управления своим настроением поэтому
очень важно не не завышать ожидания и не
ждать от этого мира там какие-то
сюрпризов это первыми второй момент что
такое например разочарование
обида и разочарование сие обида это
несбывшиеся правда ные ожидания то
разочарование это несбывшиеся надежды
раза чувствуете разницу
сбывшаяся надежда здесь не оправданное
ожидание а потом надо управлять
ожиданиями и
надеждами вот недаром когда в темном
заходит за контурный не верь не проси и
не боюсь не бойся ну а не сразу законы
так песню то тоники
поэтому не ожидая и не гаси и в этой
есть определенные права когда
настроечного эти правила то тебя искали
выбить будет очень сложно потому что
события которые происходят с нами во
внешней жизни управлять мы имеем почти
не можем но управлять мы можем своим
отношением к этим событиям при условии
что мы заранее для себя этот триггер нём
как отреагирует вот я
пример своим дочкам говорю тоже просто
утром когда встаете первую фразу которую
вы себя задайте вопрос скажите я сегодня
выбирая прожит радостный день или как
получится и когда в постели чищу еще и
же не стучит что вверх я выбираю
радостный день вроде пустая фраза но
зато когда цемент и хочет и каждая
возвращаешься якорь и такого я живу
программирую это же мой выбор до что я
сегодня выбрал сегодняшний провести
работает
сегодня выбрал так вот радость и счастье
это выбор это не то что с вами случается
автоматически это выбор ты сам выбираешь
кем быть радостным и счастливым либо
кукси сцена
ну по поводу радостей согласен по поводу
счастьем ничего не кажется ли куда путь
урона то что части и тоже что-то лут в
конце том что нас ждет не факт части как
раз таки процесс далеко она она не в
конце оно вот оно здесь и сейчас пути
теперь давайте ребята начнется наша
передач потихоньку приближается за
экватор
сейчас минуточку давайте поговорим про
22 года намечается сейчас 21 год сейчас
напоминает
достаточно
напоминаю вам сегодня 21 год еще
для творческих людей которым не
планируют важно наверное вы измеряя
только до обрезки видео мини стали 21
год во-первых
большинство людей сейчас подводит итоги
года и планирует в двадцать втором году
совершить рывок
сбросить вес добиться всех своих мечт и
так далее мы всегда либо с понедельника
у нас три года
герой ты бы сперва января так вот
давайте наверное предложим или скажем
лайфхаки которые вы могли бы
порекомендовать людям для того чтобы как
то либо в не перед планированием свою
жизнь либо повысить эффективность того
планируем которые существуют либо
какие-то любые советы чтобы людям
достичь из твоих мечт или целями
кто сортами если можно я хочу поделиться
лайфхакам который
ну неким инсайтов для себя
раз обучение я получил очень важно она
вроде звучит просто но глубокая такая
мысль простые задачи для будет простых
решений сложной задачи они требуют серию
простых решений это казалось бы ну как
бы очевидная вещь до серия простых
решений она часто очень мы пытаемся под
сложное решение подобрать точнее по
сложную задачу подобрать какое-то
сложное решение и планировала 22 год
наверняка мы планируем какие-то сложные
проекты которые требуют сложных решений
так вот не требуют таких сложных решений
не требуют ряда простых решений большого
слона да да зарезаться
так алеши но у меня был супер удачный
2021 год с финансовой точки зрения это
самый прибыльный за все 40 годов 40 лет
моей жизни и до то есть на следующий год
у меня запланирована
это лишь нет лет вот в этом отношении да
вот прям год был суперские спасибо
огромное там всевышнему кому кто
посодействовал этому там партнером
2022 год у меня распланированы только
путешествия то есть это таиланд в январе
феврале это кении потом получаются
турции соединенные штаты америки в
аляску собрался я да то есть и как бы
самый главный совет который я могу дать
это то чтобы вы испытывали кайфа потому
что вы делаете для этого просто надо
найти чем бы вы хотели заниматься всю
жизнь и тогда с планированием не будет
проблем потому что все ваши планирование
будет связано с делами от которых вы
испытываете кайф вот ну то есть это
наверное самый такой совет который я
могу дать как сибарит
классно
я обычно мне нравилась такая раньше я
тенденция у государства
когда в школе училась они каждый год
называли каким то год учителя вот начало
от медицины вот я также каждый год для
себя сделку так цен то есть мне есть
этом сопутствующие проекты но вот свечи
год и времени год музыки то есть я
сейчас понял что все я готов к к
полноценным музыкант выпускать свои
работы и мы запустили вот новое шоу
очень сильного хорошо прям и съешь меня
под годом музыки и
вот после стиль
вы зашли на самом деле
почему ее не
раз работал года я 10 на бал за
поставили сюда потому что это было
оценит зайти чём фишка то что когда ты
готовишь что-то очень долго типа два
года тыс это все вычитала а у тебя нету
продаж блин ну просто и потому что
алгоритме тюнина почему пришли все блин
это было круто я говорю но до
вечера до 5 января
[музыка]
музыка выжидая всем инструменты каждый
попадает
интенсивным а мы должны были купить
билеты бесплатно приглашали
[смех]
вот короче я выбираю какой-то год и для
мелкого акцентирующей но перед этим что
делал вот тоже рекомендую чтобы понять
чем тебе заниматься акцентировать я
реально используем медитацию просто
ухожу ну там на полчаса-час со сми него
просто копаюсь да и это мне тоже
помогает когда меня детка на предложение
мне вот сомнения делать не делать я
начал уходить полностью в будущем
моделирую ситуацию в котором я в которой
я делаю это задание
проект есть на чувство какое-то
отторжение внутренняя непонятно не
вызванная чем все это защите мою потому
что я уже на начальном этапе часы что
что то не так вот и у меня ещё столько
программка simple light она очень
простая то есть я в центре стою я я
начинает себя ветки делать да то есть
кто какие проекты делаю в этом году у
меня такая карта карты желаний нет
картриджей фотографии планирование май
майнд да то есть называется бесплатно
весим понимает и
оттуда мне уже понятно что
структурирована что я я буду делать
применять
но чтобы глобально прессе название года
давать да да я выбираю
тематику года то сестре и например ярче
что здоровая прошлый год был год
здоровья и ну я его принципе выхожу
сейчас в идеальный свой вес концу года
вышел и
записался в клуб все в горы тогда теперь
у меня музыка вот и я уже себя
программирую чтобы будет очень много
концертов очень много знакомств
коллабораций съемок
клипов выпусков итак
то есть майн майн да и на кромку дат
главный акцент годы
ну я чтобы не рекламировать платформу
вот здесь где то вы увидите наверное
если сработает ребята аннотацию на видео
на этом же канале кто называется оказал
планирование как основа счастливой жизни
вот это ветер адекватная она поменяла
полностью мою жизнь и просто почему
именно это видео там есть такое
такая вещь как могу открыть рассказать
как выгрузка а вот поставим сейчас
подходит я щас скажу всем и говорю ей
внутрь может не планировать может ничего
делать из ты хочешь просто выгрузить это
тоже очень мне кажется помогает человеку
то есть в чём там суть прискакала к это
одна мысль одна один страх
переживание планы и мечты
дела все выгружается на одну карточку
как бы 1
1 mastercard а потому если одна карточка
да это все выгружается у вас из головы
потому что это точно работает вас голова
как бы освобождается ну что я даже
поделюсь когда вы сказали какой лайфхак
как бы и вот на следующий год какие
планы выслали ребята делиться я понял
даже вот опять таки внутри этого
планирования у меня запланирован день
когда я буду об этом думать ну то есть я
вообще не думаю о том чувствующим году
буду делать видео сети без напрягов
несколько на автомате то есть вниз к
спасти что тут слышу когда я не знаю я
знаю что будет день у
подъезда и в месяц будет один день в это
тоже как лайфхак доступу уделите этому
какое-то время вашему планом а я сейчас
не знаю я об этом не переживаю вот опять
таки за выгрузки ищу который год назад
из об этом не переживаю не думаю не могу
перечислить что-то насыщен буду будил я
просто тяну и начну как бы вот
анализировать плохой год выгружаться ну
в этом году и буду думать судьба ротора
дело пошло ты это делаешь тему я делаю
на на карточка в доске ну как бы сегодня
сейчас я думаю что я просто но на
планшете буду делать 2 потому что мне
уже так удобнее очень органично
ухты
хожу и всем людям году было страха если
хотите просто щас самое время я вам не
говорил этого я не говорил это сентябре
просто сейчас конец года это очень
удобно давайте выгрузить здесь если это
ваша неважно поставлен будет ну
естественно не просто хожу когда вот
люди как говорят каковы этому ты не знаю
что тут и переживаем точно станет ли
можно еще карточки
[смех]
это мощнейший это починишь основном
основа основная философия заключает том
что голова это не сервер для хранения
информации и страхов голова это
процессор для принять решение
соответственно чтобы процесса работал у
нас голова работает только в двух
режимах либо переживает следующий способ
решить проблему как на харда скинуть все
что
один страх но листочек вот мой страх
беспокойство на рис . вот моя мечта моя
цель .
это будет
выгрузка на самом деле стоит это лучше
на разный формат
явно будут за тоже держаться а я всегда
формируя этом цели на год генеральной
линии все остальное сперва скажем так
погружаясь вопрос а
все-таки
поменялось ли там видение на жизнь да то
есть и снова философия миссия стране
потом но типа там смотрю уже теперь на
свою цель 2030 года достроили наехали
зрителям square да я сейчас про это и
говорю что все таки прежде чем делать
там планирование на год вперед до на 22
нынешний я смотрю на не поменялось
снимаю философия жизни
миссия моей там стратегические цели и
задачи если все там с ними нормы
поменяли если если как меняются их
меняем то есть от туда еду а потом
возвращаясь сюда в год что допустим
главная цель года она все таки должна в
моем случае отвечать моим стратегическим
задачам неведению эмиссии жизни и
если все норм то тогда я ее спокойно
продумываю я кстати со всеми с вами
согласен чтобы от все о чем говорите
нужно делать и потом уже иду от
генеральной цели года какие-то уже там
по линиям жизни разложить но считаю что
допустим целей на год немного не должно
быть то есть если у меня допустим 6 ними
жизни то в идеале я выбираю одну главную
цель две-три там четыре максимум 5
второстепенных а остальное все я думаю
что ну в процессе приложатся то есть это
лично допустим моё мнение то есть не
нужно стать много цели на год нужно
стать главной цели которые к которому же
подтянуть какие-то тактические задачи и
ежедневные рутинные операционные так
далее но все таки хочется чтобы мы там
при планировании не уходили в какой-то
там планирование ради планирования
загоняться как вот там о чем сегодня
говорили чтобы остаться без энергии
все-таки чтобы эти планирования и задача
мистики согласен приносили удовольствия
чтобы они нам давали энергии да они
наоборот забирали то есть это та же
многие пишут перед новым годом 31
декабря плана
кто-нибудь находил перечитывал сжигают
не
одни пишут
мне это пробивать здесь 1 декабря пишу
себе и
я пишу
когда пишу каждый гость
всегда разная
алкоголь поэтому он потом не помню
я тоже хочу поделиться своими лайфхаками
я хотел бы пожелать вам каждый день в
следующем году выделяйте и всего один
час времени который посвящаете
планированию и повышению эффективности и
ваших ежедневных действий просто в этот
час либо читайте книжки про
эффективность либо планируйте либо
размышляйте что вы в следующий раз
можете сделать более круто более
эффективно и так далее это первый второй
лайфхак я бы порекомендовал рекомендовал
вам в следующем году внедрить всего
шесть привычек всего шесть привычек дело
в том что каждый человек в течение дня
90 95 процентов ученые утверждают
решение в течение дня принимает на
основе привычка соответственно если
брать вашу 100-летнюю жизнь под 90 95
лет вы живете по привычкам то есть я
называю это по заводским установкам это
неосознанная жизнь так вот когда вы
начинаете завод заводские установки
меняет на и привычки которые вы сами
выбрали вы начинаете жить той жизнью
которую вы выбрали сами поэтому не
замахиваетесь на большое внедрите всего
шесть привычек в следующем году и всегда
помните что самые большие изменения в
жизни происходят из маленьких ежедневных
вот это очень важно и заканчиваем нашу
передачу и хотел бы всех поздравить с
наступающим 20 м годом все ребята
наверное вкратце пробежите льсти и
выскажете свое пожелание я желаю в
наступающем году вам удачи здоровья и
успехов
ваши пожелания
пусть обойдут в семейной стороной
принципе все что я хотел сказать тенгиз
друзья счастье счастье чтобы в части
всегда был и в работе и в семье и что у
вас все было хорошо мы сегодня же в
рамках планирования говорим да я
все-таки попрошу это слово две вещи
хотел бы сказать мне на правах рекламы
все-таки я желаю и рекомендую посмотреть
на маргулан info а ну курс о
планировании что это будет очень
эффективно даже хотя просто теоретически
знать эти знания не на правах рекламы я
искренне там фанат этого курса и буду
его функция 6 первое и второе вопросе
планирование желаю и рекомендую подумать
ещё не на тему того что я хочу
достигнуть и внедрить а на тему того что
я уберу для того чтобы быть эффективнее
я потому что мы очень часто думаем о том
что мы хотим внедрение чего мы хотим
достичь а я вот допустим очень много
размышлял в окончании года сейчас что я
уберу в будущем году и своей жизни до
что мне уже не нужно и тащу это тот
багаж я думаю это тоже будет очень
эффективным лайфхакам желаю вам вот
этого пожелания я хочу позвать чтобы вот
если вы использовали вот саму
планирование то надо не забывать и
конечной цели что это быть счастливым то
есть пожечь счастливую жизнь то о чем
говорят на этом канале поэтому хочу что
следующем году пожелать что все более
счастливы испытывали это ощущение как
процессе
я желаю в первую очередь доверие ну что
слишком мало доверить сейчас друг другу
к науке я желаю доверие перу очередь
вселенной богу не важно как то назвать
ее себе потому что вы невероятно крутые
просто сами боитесь этого признаться
себе в этом боитесь боитесь что то
сделать чтобы доказать себе что вы
крутые поэтому делайте дерзайте все
получится и предугадывая некоторые
комментарии не желая что все чему это
очень полезного подкаста
что так друзья мы на этом заканчиваем
наш второй выпуск нашего подкастов
пожалуйста внизу в комментариях пишите
все что вы думаете о нас лучше лучше
писать чем держать их при себе и
выскажете свое отношение понравилось вам
или нет и вообще чтобы вы предложили нам
подправить изменить и еще мы ждем от вас
новые темы на которые вы хотели бы
послушать беседу такую непринужденную
беседу и ответы людей из разных сфер
успешных людей поэтому мы с
удовольствием будем выполнять ваши
пожелания пишите какие темы вам были бы
интересны
все вещи о которых мы сегодня говорили о
платформе можете внизу в описании
посмотреть итак еще раз вам вас новым
2020 вторым годом желаем вам удачи и
счастья здоровья всем участникам большое
спасибо большое спасибо и всем кто по ту
сторону камер всем ребятам вам тоже
большое спасибо он тебя благодаря
суперски
[музыка]